carson city is abuzz again as lawmakers
convene for the 2021
session the i-team's david charns is
live outside of the legislature in the
state capitol
with a preview of what we can expect
over the next few days
and months david
well sasha things get started here in
carson city at 11 o'clock tomorrow
morning as you see it has
snowed here the past couple of days
different than home though
covid is changing the way that business
is done this year
the building behind me restricted to
just lawmakers and staff
no friends and family and for everyone
else you're going to have to weigh in
virtually
now if you're unfamiliar the legislative
session is when lawmakers meet for four
months to vote on a budget and make new
laws
and they have a lot to get to first and
foremost how to balance the state's
nearly nine
billion dollar budget amid the pandemic
that has devastated our economy
democrats and republicans will have to
come together finding ways to get
nevadans vaccinated
and back to work they're also focusing
on funding our schools health care
including medicaid
and what to do with money our state
received from the federal government to
prop us up
we talked to leadership on both sides
earlier this month about what some of
these conversations are going to look
like
we already made uh some tough decisions
and cut our state budget by 30
um and that's a state budget that was
already one of the most lean in the
country so
we're going to have to you know live
within our means and deal with the
further budgets you know restraints i
think you're going to see a continuation
of a lot of those cuts uh
due you know due to the revenue
shortfall from you know
the governor's closures
the one thing we will likely see is
republicans finger-pointing to governor
sislek
though of course he followed federal
guidelines from former president trump a
republican
and the cdc in regards to the shutdown
republicans may also try to rein in the
governor's executive power though
that would fail with democrats in power
here
republicans did gain seats in november
but democrats do remain in control of
both the senate and the assembly
though they no longer have super
majorities
meaning they also have to make some
agreements this time around
now also in the majority this year are
women
get this the nevada state legislature is
the only legislature in the entire
country with both
on both the senate and house side the
assembly side
with women outnumbering men we have a
lot of information on eightnewsnow.com
right now about how you can weigh in
virtually this year
and also what will be talked about
during the legislative session in the
coming days
for now live in carson city tonight i'm
david charns 8 news now